that's so odd but that was one that got
brought up as well that was also in the
middle of a huge conversation about you
know Benghazi and the Iran deal those
are the two things are two of the three
things that I like to do on Twitter
although I'm no longer on there you got
off yeah bad for you yeah I was glad to
see Kanye West got off to did he yeah
what deleted all his account last week
and I was glad to cuz you're just like
what's your a target it's just too
painful
yeah well definitely shouldn't be
reading that [ __ ] no I don't read it
yeah but well when you become a target
how do you know if you don't read it
well I'd know what I'd lived through
when first happened and that's been like
four or so months ago so I just know how
I've reacted in my locker real life
since that happened to me how long he's
died off to die off slow down where they
weren't just coming after you constantly
like I told you that news crews when
they found out that you were gonna come
on the podcast the first time they were
trying to show up at my house they were
trying to show up at the studio they
were trying to find me at The Comedy
Store yeah I mean they were just trying
to hunt down yeah anything about you I
know I've sneaking cigs from my
boyfriend so we're at my mom's house
when I did it you know we were at home
in Salt Lake City when I tweeted at two
11 a.m. I just woke up and Trey I had
this thought in my head oh my god this
can make so much sense and then I
tweeted it and I went right back to
sleep and when I woke up at 7 this [ __ ]
hit the fan you know yeah but I was like
I'm going to expound on this later there
was one of those kind of things right
you just want to get it down and I you
know always slept with my computer and
tweet when I wake up like you know when
you're old you have to have the bathroom
a lot saw his tweet and fall back to
sleep see and I and then on the ambien
tweets my daughter I used to always when
I took my ambien I called my daughter
and she or she called me she goes mom
you're starting to do the ambien tweets
get off get off the Twitter you know but
so I just called my daughter then every
night when I
when I was doing the ambien and I'd go
you know what here comes a big fish chic
recorded it here comes a big fish right
through my window oh oh he's getting
stuck in the mirror and she that's what
she goes mom turn it all off and go I
have to have my family telling me that
cuz he almost need her standing guard by
your bed yeah hold on let me read that
before you tweet it no no no she doesn't
now she don't she took my Twitter
account away will you sir program she
tweets all these liberal things that I
want to get just get up in her face and
smack her around for not with you know
on her own but I'm like wow come it's
okay for you to say this but it ain't
for me well mother I didn't lose
everything
oh really trying to help you oh my god
you and your [ __ ] help sticks in your
face is just this year a serious liberal
they all off three and my daughters are
serious social justice warrior types and
what do they think about your positions
well they think I'm a friggin crepe they
think I'm crazy they always did like you
know they always thought all my choice
for president were crazy but then oddly
they were all very supportive when I
personally ran for president in 2012
they were really supportive of me but
well you're their mom yeah that was cool
but like all the other times it's like
oh god mother it's your generation it's
a baby boomers are the reason everything
is all [ __ ] up
so stop letting yourself off the hook
political conversation that's in the bar
household yeah oh yeah oh yeah